dans notre chambre dit si vous n'avez
pas d'acier vous n'avez pas de pays
sa logique c'est que ça a saigné
aluminium c'est difficile de construire
des tanks ou de fabriquer des armes
[Musique]
darif du président g vise donc à
protéger les usines américaines qui
fabrique l'acier l'aluminium surtout les
chinois parce que les chinois on a un
mois peuvent produire plus d'acier
d'aluminium que les américains quand un
homme est l'argument de la sécurité
nationale peut aussi être vu comme une
stratégie visant à contourner les
accords commerciaux selon les règles de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
un pays qui utilisent la clause de
sécurité nationale peut se soustraire à
l'arbitrage
autrement dit lohan c'est ne pourrait
même pas intervenir mais c'est une
stratégie qui est potentiellement
dangereuse les chinois pourraient faire
exactement la même chose sur des
produits américains
il y aurait donc un risque réel de
guerre commerciale que l'om c'est ne
pourrait pas arbitré selon new york
times les tarifs du président entrant
presqu'aussi de diviser les américains
eux mêmes le prix de l'acier l'aluminium
risque inévitablement d'augmenter donc
les avions de beaux et où les voitures
de foi hindoue les tracteurs de quatre
pêcheurs vont coûter plus cher à
produire
aux états unis il ya 80 fois plus
d'emplois dans les usines qui fabriquent
des biens à partir de l'acier de
l'aluminium qui a des emplois dans les
alumineries où les aciéries en 2002 jon
boscia imposer des tarifs de 30 % sur
l'acier et dans les mois qui ont suivi
d'ailleurs deux cent mille américains
qui ont perdu leur emploi entre autres
parce que le prix de l'acier avait trop
augmenter
[Musique]